it's late afternoon in mexico city
and rosa silva is out searching for her
daughter victoria lisbeth who went
missing last year
an anonymous phone call has led rosa to
a part of the city that's popular among
sex workers
she believes whomever took her daughter
may have forced her into prostitution
all of this is in hopes of finding my
daughter victoria it would be the
greatest thing that could happen for us
to find her during one of these searches
that we carry out with the help of elena
elena is the founder of an ngo that
seeks to help people like rosa in their
search for missing loved ones
some time ago we received a phone call
it was a woman's voice she said she had
seen rosa's daughter among the girls out
here
elena's organization has started a
campaign called cuartos vasilos or empty
rooms in spanish
their main objective is to raise
visibility over the crisis of missing
persons in mexico by symbolically
renting out the rooms of missing women
the money they raise is used to help
families fund the search for their loved
ones
this room once belonging to rosa's
daughter victoria is just one of tens of
thousands of empty rooms across mexico
though victoria has been missing for
more than a year rosa has kept
everything just the way it was the day
her daughter disappeared
something tells me my daughter is alive
but where is she i wish i could just
turn the corner and see her and hold her
i dream of her constantly in my dreams i
see my daughter smiling i see her coming
home
i have faith that i will find my
daughter all i ask is for god to give me
the strength to continue this struggle
apart from the pain of not knowing where
victoria is or if she's even alive rosa
has all but spent her life savings
trying to find her
and in mexico it's a story that plays
out every day in households all across
the country
more than 22 100 women are currently
listed as missing in mexico and more
than half of them are under the age of
18. the crisis of missing persons in
mexico is so massive that every day an
average of six women go missing most of
them will never be seen or heard from
again
as weeks and months have passed with no
updates on victoria's whereabouts many
have lost faith of ever finding her
alive
rosa however refuses to give up hope
vowing to never give up the search for
her daughter
manuel rapalo al jazeera mexico city